all right here we go
could go powerplant
probably bad idea but you know me I
wonder what happens if you line in the
[ __ ] big squash dinner or whatever
it's called
we got company
it's to be expected
okay we got at least one
[ __ ] I'm gonna plan on the roof great
just what I are great that's another guy
here that's mine that's mine
hell yeah where you go son
that never rain boy the [ __ ] did he go
there
great oh hell yeah
[Laughter]
[ __ ] random ass and never [ __ ] get
a gun in the beginning all right
gonna go in the outskirts better be out
of looking in then looking at Oh
nothing Jesus Christ man Oh got him a
lot of fasts a die in the beginning with
no armor what the [ __ ]
Jesus Christ mr. picked up every gun in
this [ __ ] area scarce my favorite
nice I'll take it
oh [ __ ] did he see me yeah yeah he
definitely saw me okay come on
he's third personing me so hard right
now if this guy had anything
this guy doesn't want to play huh
see if we can sneak up on him [ __ ] I
have too many options Jesus says no I'll
keep got a [ __ ] pretty good loadout
nope I guess
oh [ __ ] I hear someone where he probably
heard me
oh wait I see him
oh I didn't think that would work I did
not think I did not Jesus
was that him though I don't know if that
was him he looked different [ __ ] I just
have to assume boy you had a lot of [ __ ]
on you boy I will take that and your
cute little helmet I should just loot
the rest of this area I got pretty
[ __ ] good loot goddamn that's a long
way to run I don't see any cars come on
[ __ ]
we're so [ __ ] I just realized
completely [ __ ] no [ __ ] car come on
ah goddamn it boy I got a drink an
energy drink man that taste good man
quit with my thirst man now I run faster
that's how it works
great red zone as well are you [ __ ]
kidding me give me a goddamn car or else
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die hate me
come on me come on man give me a cup I
need a cup me
it's gonna go in the south
everyone's already taken all the
vehicles this should be the trailer for
this game cuz this is what you're gonna
yes [ __ ] yes
there is hope there is hope everyone the
Bungie come up my pop some pills as you
do before you drive don't pop pills and
drive brooch
I mean sisters
[Applause]
[ __ ] we're still gonna take a lot of
damage
boy the [ __ ] is shooting me
I'm gonna camp here or [ __ ] this issue
to me [ __ ] [ __ ] don't worry all part of
the plan well I don't see anyone where
Oh
oh there is it's a road with the [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] idiot [ __ ] free kill Jesus
Christ thank [ __ ]
nope god dammit that'll cool for a
minute hey I'm gonna drive up to you in
the car and jump out in front of you
please don't kill me
I might as well cross
I'm gonna be the troll troll of the
bridge do you guys have that fairy tale
with a troll under the bridge and then
the box had to cross and one of them
tells there's a small one in the middle
one and the big one cool just check-in I
[ __ ] it it ain't worth it main it ain't
worth it
whoa what
what the [ __ ] are you doing you're not
gonna get me with a [ __ ] shotgun he's
gonna know by banks bah look big a
killer boy 69 pro tip don't shoot at
cars if you're having an open [ __ ]
field Jesus Christ
domo arigato for the free stuff
big boy killer
skirts good
about the [ __ ] sake lees another one now
now just [ __ ] this car does not have
enough health it's gonna explode same
bye-bye I can't believe all this find a
safe spot [ __ ] I meant to do that don't
worry about it it's a stretchy hey told
you guys totally I meant to do it let's
just rest up
drink some drink some energy drinks pop
some pills sorry that was disgusting
everything's gonna be okay
Hey look at that I didn't realize I had
that hell yeah
[ __ ] you holographic and go suck a dick
holographic can go suck a holographic
dick am i right give me that [ __ ] boy
all right let's see whether a circle
Lance great absolutely just where I want
are there's a car there I shall take it
hopefully I won't get shot from this
epic epic maneuver
you might as well go through this
[ __ ] house see what we can find and
that is more coverage thank you very
much
but
brand-new let's go
all right we're gonna go straight for
the middle baby
hopefully there's no-one there already I
find that a lot of times you think you
think you're there's gonna be a bunch of
people but really there's no one we're
gonna do a little lash sneaky-sneak
we're gonna Park it right here that's
right that's right
but we're gonna go in this one or maybe
the shed
hell yeah they'll never expect a shed
that's right who would go in the shed no
one no one would go in the shed no one
would expect anyone in the shed
[ __ ]
[Music]
I am the shine hell yeah what the [ __ ] I
want to scare the [ __ ] out of him he
didn't even shoot this [ __ ] no one
suspects the shed well now it's pretty
obvious I mean the [ __ ] shed if
there's a dead body in front of it there
we go
do it and if you open it outwards seems
like someone left the shed
I really like my I'm pretty [ __ ]
decked out military vest wouldn't hurt
come on white circle come on I pray to
the every night every night white circle
pretty comfy in here all right what do
we got hell yeah that's what I'm [ __ ]
talking about I'm getting [ __ ]
nervous I don't expect this to be a win
but [ __ ] okay
oh [ __ ] I think you saw me too yeah he
definitely no wait the [ __ ] is he doing
is he trying to sneak up on me no he
didn't see me we'll do the same on him
then
[ __ ] no no oh my [ __ ] god [ __ ] one
is loopback [ __ ] I ran out of [ __ ]
ammo Jesus
nice one I think a mountain has to be
safe for people
could be anywhere there's no way they're
gonna come they're down to three I'm in
the circle
maybe I lit too far in the circle just
realized look there's one
thought I saw someone
nice there yes [ __ ] did he see me I
think he did
[ __ ] had a free kill there come on
circle still in it I think
burnsy
I think he has to run
GSS where
okay well thanks for showing yourself
baby [ __ ] I almost had him it's a
[ __ ] potato shot worse than me he's
healing now [ __ ] that's my turn
great is this the last circle like the
very last oh [ __ ] yes it's done can't do
[ __ ] is that all you got boy he's trying
to fake me out what is that gonna do
nibble what is that the blue is
squeezing my ass legit like I can't move
backwards a second like a [ __ ] was he
doing shut the [ __ ] up
might as well boost give it all I got
what is he thinking I should do the
trick
well this is lame come on baby don't be
shy come on baby
[ __ ] I think the only way to finish this
[ __ ] [ __ ] if I get a headshot like
otherwise we're just gonna keep poking
at each other come on oh I thought I
died what the [ __ ] yeah then I get the
[ __ ] headshot did I get the headshot
I gotta watch replay I don't [ __ ]
believe it
my [ __ ] strategy worked oh [ __ ] I
got the [ __ ] headshot hell yeah oh
that feels so [ __ ] good I feel so
[ __ ] great so many times I doubted
myself that game I was like that [ __ ] I
could I can't do it I'm not skilled
enough but with a little bit of luck
hell yeah I just got to get ahead I know
I had to Tang a couple shots but I
didn't think I would actually land the
[ __ ] head shy he had a [ __ ] level
3 helmet jeez says
I was [ __ ] awesome I'm the [ __ ]
King